okay we're back it's Tuesday watching
the world fall apart watching the world
phone yeah it's uh Kickstarter's falling
apart
do you know that no I didn't yeah
they're [ __ ] up IndieGoGo is taking
over that see what else is going on oil
industries [ __ ] falling apart that's
gonna I can't believe that oil is like
negative it was like negative $27 a
barrel couldn't give it away that that's
like a very dangerous man that's the
energy sector that [ __ ] goes boy we all
go but you know whatever doesn't I knew
about it I'm just you know like I said
I'm [ __ ] going Morton's Joe on these
mothers get my half-life war boys which
was on list what we gonna talk about
well gosh lots of things it's like it's
kind of hard to follow that up cuz she's
like well everything sucks everything
well see how it was yeah we're just
trying to like cheer people up in the
[ __ ] apocalypse I'm [ __ ] at least
Florida's mostly open yes mostly open
it's gonna I think that's good you know
it's gonna go state-by-state like I said
like like Nostradamus predicted you know
we'll see one thing that actually really
made me smile this morning was I was out
on my walk as I do every morning and on
the path I saw this older couple and
they were taking their kitty out for a
walk we're not gonna do it the kitty was
out in there and it was like in a baby
stroller I'm not gonna do it Jay our
kitty would not do that she wouldn't
stay in that thing for that five seconds
that's what I'm saying well that's why I
was amazed because I'm like looking I'm
like is that a kitty you're like in a
baby it's like one of those strollers
that has like that netting like dome
thing over it and then there's a hole in
the top so the kitty was like sticking
over time just like looking around going
like where the [ __ ] yeah but then you do
that [ __ ] better happier I'll have the
other dudes making fun of me like I she
gave birth to a kitty
wonder who the daddy I did they don't
know what daddy was the dad was part cat
Tony the Tiger
it was
yes but yeah so the well the thing about
it is I was really impressed because I
have we thought about when we first got
the kitten
well Pookie was a kitten when we did
think about like taking her for a walk
it's definitely getting her a little
harness and stuff but to be honest I
don't think she would she wouldn't walk
on it she would walk on it and I know
dragging her yeah and I think too if you
um like took her out on the path even in
a stroller she was just the first time
she saw like a lizard or a squirrel she
was just like boy and she'd be like
woman go get it so it was a stroller but
it was sealed up yeah come on well she
could have come out it was like a big
hole it was it a cat stroller or a human
baby stroller it looked like a human
baby stroller okay I mean it but it
looked like one of those ones that had
like a netting over the top like just on
another eyes and stuff but there's still
a hole like a big hole in the top I
don't know I'm not an expert in baby
strollers I don't I don't even know if
they make like I can't specifically
enjoy yeah yeah yeah it was just like
sticking out of the top like it was a
[ __ ] convertible or some [ __ ]
we feel like a little off white cat big
yellow I see she's talking about some I
wanted to do one time I wanted to make a
backpack for the cat yeah
riding you know yeah just going like
master-blaster out of damn mad bag yeah
yeah well I always get jealous every
time I see like um people's videos cuz
didn't think that one guy can't wear
what his name is but he's like some kind
of like adventurer like he goes all over
the world and like jumped off bridges
with [ __ ] bungee cords and whatever
and he takes the kitty everywhere he
goes like around the world and like the
kitty just like rides along with him
like in his backpack or like it was on a
leash goes in the water at the beach and
[ __ ] I'm like cookie would not do that I
think we mentioned it one time where was
this girl we ran into a couple times
she's a friend of a friend she walked
into this club that we go to well spot
what bills pop yeah and I think there's
a live event going on there was yeah
yeah I walk in and she just got damn
sphynx cat
it puts it puts it on the table in this
face just walk around chilling out
anyway hello sweater on yeah sweater on
like a gremlin it did and I I couldn't
believe it that that cat wasn't just
running around everywhere but I guess
when they're in the air
they're not really totally comfortable
they just stay where you put him
although yeah he didn't see my shirt or
anything he just like walked around and
let everybody pet him and he's like hey
did she put him in a book bag wasn't a
book bag
pervs that he was like some kind of
folding box it reminded me of like a
McDonald's Happy Meal yeah he's drives
along like he's riding an elephant yeah
put a hat on didn't have a hat I was
sure he had like a sweater a stocking
cap or something oh maybe he did she had
a little half of the rubberband on him
that is wearing it I always wonder like
does Fink's kitties need like sweaters
and stuff because aren't they cold like
without fur I guess you'd think that cuz
they're negative what was the name that
cat she goes see that's a like bugging
me because I can't
he had like a really cool name and it's
like driving me crazy because I can't
[ __ ] remember it I feel like he was
named after something like from a movie
but I didn't like it was gizmo or
something like that but that wasn't it
but you know what I mean maybe maybe I
just thought it was weird yeah I never
liked that cuz normally if you I mean if
you took Pookie somewhere she'd be
freaking the [ __ ] out she'd be freaking
the [ __ ] out and she'd like just hide
under the [ __ ] table and stuff and
she's not real skittish like if you like
when we had friends over and stuff
she'll hide for a little while but then
she'll come out and be like hey what are
you doing yeah whereas Beijing is like
avocado yeah she'll come and sit on your
stuff like as soon as you come in she's
like yeah and then she'll like if you
bring a purse or something she'll just
like sit on it alright so what else
going on I wanted to mention I wanted to
mention too that Pookie brought in a
baby snake the other day into the house
really brought it in same one no youyou
okay wrestled it it wasn't house oh it
wasn't inside no she had it out I
thought she brought it in and I'm like I
didn't let her back
yeah little foot long snake yeah she's
alright yeah we rescued it oh I also
want to say just before we started
recording this I got a little package
from one of our patrons whose name is
Eric Oates
this is a true crime book I'm very
excited about reading this one called
death in a prairie house okay cool about
the mass murder at the frank lloyd
wright's
tell Taliesin Taliesin house which I had
heard of before but I don't actually
know that much about it but you know how
I love to read about mess thank you very
much um I'm still on the first chapter
because like I said I mean I'm working
on it like a little bit every day but
it's a lot of cases so I'm still working
on the year 2000 like I said I'm just
hoping that I have the first three
they're still steady yeah okay
yeah selling a few copies every day and
that's pretty cool that's mostly what's
selling every now and then poor
paranormal stuff sells too but I feel
like the true crime probably sells
bigger market it is yet but yeah I have
and I've actually been working on it
today I wasn't working on it just like
right before we started recording good I
was researching the Amanda to Singh case
in [ __ ] where the hell was it
Arkansas Jonesboro Arkansas yeah that
happened in 2002 super weird case but
yeah that was the one I was just writing
about before we recorded this what else
have we got going on what it's Tuesday
right yeah yeah I'm just watching
YouTube watching people [ __ ] up yes
people are [ __ ] up I called it well
you know I called it although you don't
you kind of called it to remember when
this [ __ ] [ __ ] first came I go that's
just gonna be kind of like I don't think
how many people are gonna die it's me
like looking at the numbers of the total
total amount of infected and then the
amount that actually died is not that
bad
yeah because the total number of
infected most of the cases are
asymptomatic means that then even know
that they have it they were doing so in
a way it's kind of scary because there's
like AI people run around because [ __ ]
man we just went to ball rained
yesterday up like there could have been
[ __ ] cooties all over the web they
think that you know mortality is in the
tenths of a percent which makes me a
little bit more it makes it only a
little bit more than a normal flu yeah
and most of the people that seem to be
dying most of them have what's called
comorbidities or they're at death's door
one of the two yeah that means you got
some other shares we got other [ __ ]
wrong with them that's the same always
yeah yeah that'd be a good band name
like for a death metal band they're a
death metal band called comorbidity
there should be no but that's all I got
that's all yeah me too probably like I
said I'm just checking in me hopefully
yeah hopefully you guys are enjoying the
three-and-a-half hour behemoth of the
show that I just [ __ ] up on that show
you did yeah I didn't remember it like
that last one third and then I cuz he
did like three cases yeah and then like
I came in while she was editing it and I
heard myself talking I'm like this
laughing remember that was funny it's
funnier when you will see I think that
too it's like every time we record in
the show like man if [ __ ] was funny I
well yeah and I'm always like feeling
like really uncomfortable it's like oh
man I messed up all my notes and I look
got lost and lost my place but then what
I entered and I'm like oh that's not too
bad it's like it's it's not ever as bad
sex
which I guess is good you think I'd have
learned that by now you try to say
something you get tongue-tied and you
slow down for a little bit to remember
what it was what you had what you were
planning on saying yeah and it seems
like the pause was like an hour-long one
yeah exactly
but then when I listen to it back it's
like it doesn't sound yeah really weird
at all I mean I know that I have like
some kind of vocal tics that I'm trying
to get rid of you saying stuff a lot
yeah that's what I'm saying but it's
just I don't know it's hard to get over
it because yeah especially since I'm not
reading off anything I'm just talking to
make away you never tell shade I'll hit
you with a roll of [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
like that
yeah it's just yeah I remember you know
when to like public speaking and stuff
and stuff Sierra said and stuff yeseo
with black speech I went through public
speaking
school the course that we had and that
was one of the things that they that
they always talked about was like the
ticks everything Azzam you don't notice
them they didn't lay people notice them
those times they did a short on Mystery
Science Theater a long time ago that was
my camper the title of the short was but
it was about public speaking and they
kind of went into that too but it's the
funny because the the guys that they had
like demonstrating like they were like
really over the top it was just kind of
like you know people can't use
appliances in a [ __ ] you know TV
infomercial type of [ __ ] where their
senator going um or like that no normal
person would talk like what's funny is
that people do it in other languages
before I understood Portuguese and I
moved to Brazil I pick up on people's
tics they kept saying the same things
over and over again yeah well it's not
even know what it was and the same thing
with like in Korea did good yeah and
you'd hear the [ __ ] pop man and it just
means yeah so yeah but he just starts
standing out a lot what's the what's the
Portuguese equivalent of and [ __ ] like
that like that it would be like view
view that's much did you see okay
it means like saying you know that's
much more succinct and they'll say you
know a lot you know you know view view
you do view be Savile Cup before it like
before you said that you were gonna hit
me with a rolled-up newspaper I thought
that you were gonna suggest a drinking
game out of it and I was like please
don't do that because people will be
dying of alcohol poisoning out there I
try to stop saying it but I can't it's I
don't know it's just hard for me to do
there were people
complaining about me ran every time Tom
Rance here on the show with me it'll be
a rant off I'm just I'm just trying to
entertain you know I'm trying to
entertain and that's gonna be yeah it's
gonna be I'm gonna rant that's how it is
that's just that's to Tom the [ __ ]
wrong the show will find its own
audience it's like if people don't like
to listen well like I said there's a
million [ __ ] shows on YouTube that I
don't give a [ __ ] about and don't want
to watch but it's like I don't watch it
YouTube's [ __ ] up they're becoming
corporatist [ __ ] their were becoming
real [ __ ] corporate well you know
they don't want to chase the money yeah
they're there they're basically trying
to become them tube where'd you get that
from I'm saying how about you anymore
it's about them they're gonna they're
trying to you know they only want
authoritative sources in other words
they want to talk they don't want us
talking that's why people join our [ __ ]
shoot it could be one day that [ __ ]
shoots all we have and if you notice man
how uncool
YouTube's getting that like the new
memes and [ __ ] don't come from YouTube
they're coming off that tick-tock
well yeah everything's cool on tick-tock
that's where all the cool kids that's
where all the Utes are it's raw to Utes
are think you this maybe we ought to try
to do something in the tick-tock sphere
somehow to promote the show I don't
think you'd do a show on ticked I only
just recently got my stupid ass on
insert one Instagram for Christ's sake
YouTube is gonna become for old people
this is gonna be the cable well it's
just kind of like Facebook when yeah
that's like Facebook is now it's for old
people yeah I think Facebook is a shadow
of its former self
I mean I still use it but I don't
usually it's getting that it's good I
mean I usually just use it to kind of
message people and post the show up
there I think kind of keep track of you
know some of our friends at why not yeah
Instagram is kind of taken over for that
it has yes and
um but maybe there's something we can do
on tick-tock to help the show I don't
think you can put up a whole show on
tick-tock probably not now there's some
of those streaming things we could
stream here though we got enough people
stream here yeah one day we'll start
we'll do some streams I think that we
should start our own video sharing
platform and call it other [ __ ]
tube yeah maybe instead of doing a daily
dang we just do a daily stream I suppose
we could I could do that so you see
people in the comment sections yeah is
there somebody online and if they start
[ __ ] with me up I can [ __ ] them up and
if they stuck with you I'll [ __ ] about
and then you know that's what we'll do
you know we'll ask them maybe people
might want a daily stream instead yeah
we're doing just like we're doing now
and we do this in one take anyway that's
true I don't think if it's live or not
because it's yeah because these are
daily so I don't really go through and
lie in it [ __ ] out of them I just the
way they are I'll just do it as a daily
stream well yeah because then it's still
like preserved if people want to watch
it later yes same thing yeah that's true
I guess spaghetti we'll just look into
how it's done you wanna do it I think
you figured it out yeah okay
I figure everything out man your
smartest [ __ ] I know all right so
that'll do it for the Tuesday show we I
guess we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow let us know if he wants to do
live stream kind of [ __ ] cuz maybe we'll
do that